hey i'm alex and this is my recipe for
strawberry cheesecake cake roll
[Music]
so i made this recipe video at a time
where cake rolls were
kind of trendy they were like the in
thing to do and i just wanted to play
around with the flavors and create
something that was delicious but also
new and interesting so the process looks
a little bit tricky when making a cake
roll because there are a few components
that you have to nail but it's actually
pretty simple when you break it down so
this cake batter calls for a lot of eggs
it's kind of like a sponge cake now you
want to make sure you're beating your
eggs before you go on to adding any
other ingredients because we're going to
incorporate some air into these eggs and
it'll make for a fluffier cake then all
the rest is pretty simple you'll just
dump in the rest of the ingredients and
switch to a folding method just to make
sure we're not over beating our cake
batter
[Music]
also just keep an eye when you're baking
this cake because it's so much thinner
it cooks really fast so be careful not
to burn your cake so now we get to some
of the more important steps once your
cake is baked you need to lay a clean
dish towel on your surface sprinkle that
with powdered sugar and then right when
you take it out of the oven you're going
to flip your cake over onto that towel
and quickly roll it up while the cake is
still hot because this will ensure once
you cool it in that form that it will
keep its roll shape without cracking a
very important step
so work quickly while it's still hot
don't burn yourselves you probably won't
it's fine but yeah the powdered sugar is
there to make sure your cake doesn't
stick to your towel so don't skip that
part either and don't use flour because
that's gross
so now your cake is cooling in its dish
towel i went on to make the filling
which is a simple kind of cheesecake
frosting it's one of my all-time
favorites so can't go wrong so when you
bring your cake back from the fridge
you're going to unroll it and it will
still have like kind of a it will still
kind of like i don't know go up
because it's like
molded to the roundness
oh man
so then you're just going to lather all
that cheesecake frosting onto
the surface of the cake you're gonna
sprinkle on some strawberries and then
it should be pretty easy from here on
out you just roll the cake back up into
its final form
this is like a shapeshifter
shapeshifter cake i sprinkled my cake
with some more powdered sugar just to
make sure the outside looked nice and
you can also decorate it with some more
like strawberries or maybe some whipped
cream also another important step for
this cake if you're going to be serving
it to people or you want it to look
really beautiful is to chop off the ends
now i know it might seem wasteful but
you're really going to get the best
visual of that swirl when you chop off
the extra bits on end but you also get
that tasty visual
you can just eat them as a snack too
i did
i don't know why i always do this
all of a sudden it's like my signature
[Music]